so what your hand see Jaime reg t27
my name is Johnny I'm mark my just said
my name is John okay okay
my name is Doyle Utah hi I'm tail I'm
the leader of an SP 27 nice to meet you
oh hey guys ma I'm so ready to take the
place
hi I'm Tay I was bit I mentioned good
luck okay and we are here with BuzzFeed
to fill out this quiz of which MCT one
to seven member are
[Music]
I get myself yeah okay let's go
first question pick an ice cream flavor
cookies and cream okay beef cheek
chocolate strawberry caramel coffee Oh
mango just just what my PJs chuckling I
love it for me I chose green tea whoa
Bonnie la Ola Ola Cheers mango green tea
cookies and cream I chose green tea
mango is okay so far which superhero is
your favorite oh this was harder cuz the
Incredibles is actually five really I'm
gonna be this specific I'm gonna do for
me I chose Batman I love watching this
whole series of Batman I watched Dark
Knight I love those stories oh yeah I
choose spider-man
he's quite a minute I Maggie Goffe Janey
I mean today I chose spider-man this was
very vibrant respond but whoa good kid
in school but he gets full and after
getting the powers he gets to win I feel
like justice I love being credible
because I can feel Oh families love yeah
yeah that's why I like these family
Thanks which NCT one t7 song represents
you the best oh I got it
Cherry Bomb two-face cherry and
I like it I choose regular regular
Buicks make money because super human I
[Laughter]
actually chose superhuman as well
regular I want to be super rich if you
won the lottery what would you buy first
hello easy let me let me think hard
oh you could go more today oh okay a new
wardrobe
I like it [ __ ] yeah application I knew
it I knew you right by the beach I chose
on a recording studio is actually one oh
um recording studio because I met song
Google monterosso o'bannon vacation home
I love traveling you want to go home
[Laughter]
that's his hometown luxury sports car oh
you want I got a car oh D oh D and she's
a Korean banking scenario
hey the side dish Tom alright I got mine
I chose Friday's mackeral mackeral
mackeral the fish mackeral mackeral well
[Music]
I also chose kimchi yeah kimchi like for
me kimchi - kimchi I can't believe we
don't think [ __ ] of course
oh I really think that Kim she's one of
the best side dishes you can have you
can make like so many foods with
machines she gay always nice kimchi
always need those of you who haven't
tried it you should try it like it's
good what song would you dance to right
now sickle mode talk by Cody talk by
Kali
himself I like it black RTV because we
sometimes really like dance with this
music I like diamonds are like seven
rings by Ariana Grande because I like
Iran keep kamal why you don't tell me
anything
keep ha I like [ __ ] oh yeah my bday
you better to talk this is what do you
morning show
[Music]
done we're done which NCT wants to
remember are you check it out I got Jana
oh my god AJ eat till you're put in five
minutes Oh Oh Cheers
like I'm actually I actually got myself
I'm pretty uh pleased to get myself you
know because I'm me nice me too
I got me oh my god - very happy
[Music]
I got J hell in there see younger they
own it on they go check out certainly a
GoPro to join you guys
tell them I'm gonna walk it over I got
because of that song cardi B I like it
yeah oh yeah oh yeah I got to exactly he
like me yeah we just took the quiz which
NCT 170 member are you really fun let's
check it out get on BuzzFeed and trap
that please you decided to take the quiz
and check it out thank you
[Music]
you